the next
major uh
piece of news coming out of russia
is the absolute and complete collapse of
russia's ruble which is the currency
r-u-b-l-e
now worth
less than one american cent
less than one american cent one of the
things that took place over the weekend
is that there have been swift bank
sanctions placed on russia now i don't
mean that they were swift and that they
were rapidly placed they weren't done
swiftly swift in all caps is an
inter-bank messaging system used to
transfer money internationally sometimes
when we have uh like an advertiser
that's based in a different country
swift codes are used to transfer money
back and forth and over the weekend it
was announced that indeed uh the there
are sanctions being placed on russia's
access to the swift system there was
every expectation that indeed the ruble
would collapse and it has collapsed
we're putting up the uh ruble dollar
exchange rate for you
and it looks like it fell off a cliff i
mean it looks like a mountain with a
seemingly vertical ledge
and the value of the ruble has
completely and totally collapsed now
obviously the problem is that this
affects
innocent russian people
who oppose this invasion more than it
affects the oligarchs and putin the the
pressure on putin and oligarchs is going
to start to build it already is building
of course restricting air travel out of
russia restricting their assets in other
countries
shutting down swift collapsing the value
of their currency there's no question
about it but it's also really affecting
the russian people we can already see
this over the weekend there were bank
runs and atm runs all over russia we're
showing video to our video audience here
of people lined up at an atm to pull
money out and the money running out so
it's an unfortunate part of the point of
sanctions
part of the point of sanctions is turn
more people against putin
and turn even more people against him
when there are already people against
him to try to put pressure on him to
stop what he's doing now does putin care
about the suffering of the russian
people it's not clear it's not clear and
this happened in um
uh
when there were sanctions
for germany for starting world war one
and it led to german people suffering
and later hitler used that to his
advantage
um but i'm hearing from russians who
oppose the invasion
that they understand it's putin who's
doing this to russia
and they are suffering as a result of
what what is going on with the ruble so
then it's easy to say well go on the
street in protest many of them are and
then they get arrested so i think we
should not
ignore the reality that a lot of what is
happening is terrible for the russian
people also there are ukrainians getting
killed
so this isn't the sort of competition
about who is most
being uh uh
who who is most brutally suffering as a
result of this there's different types
of suffering and of course
most people would say i'd rather be poor
than die
meaning
have the ruble be worth nothing in
russia versus potentially get killed in
ukraine but obviously this is all much
more complicated than that now another
comment i received is communal pain
often will lead to communal action and
the idea that if the russian people now
all suffer together because of what's
going on with the ruble then
what then what is the question because
many of the protesters end up getting
arrested also not to be ignored is that
the ukrainian currency is suffering as
well we're putting now up on the screen
the the currency chart
of the ukrainian rivnia
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
also way down not as much as the ruble
on a percentage basis so in addition to
the bombing happening in ukraine and the
invasion happening in ukraine ukrainian
currency also taking
a major hit and uh we will continue to
see
whether these negotiations that are
reportedly starting between ukraine and
russia
lead anywhere over the next 24 hours
you can support the david pakman show by
supporting our sponsors and one of those
sponsors is sheath underwear
traditional underwear involves sticking
sweating the dreaded chafing sheath
underwear are boxer briefs
specifically designed to keep everything
separate cool dry and comfortable they
have a bunch of great designs options to
choose from more minimal styles
their signature geometric pattern
waistband is cool there's really
something for everybody but the most
important thing is you stay cool during
the day and at night
upping your comfort to the next level
read the reviews online sheath underwear
has been a game changer for many men
give it a try they have super fast
shipping you'll get your order in just a
few days and don't forget that you'll
get 20 off when you go to sheath
underwear dot com slash pacman and use
the code pacman the link is down below